is very very nice trap so can you get
king h1 what a move just stepping out of
all the checks on f4 any knight moves
wesley is about to lose this to be
honest because how do you defend against
rookie two how do you defend against
queen h7 and once again we go back to
this moment when he played this age five
i'm very sorry to interrupt but the game
between richard report and bratislav
voice check has officially ended in a
draw
meaning that rapport will advance to the
semi-finals playing against nakamura
we will be here tomorrow to uh to join
the action yeah this is gonna be this is
gonna be fantastic and robert cass
uh made an amazing job to come back from
literally nothing he was so close
uh they're sitting on a 50 square and
somehow he made it even worse it was
something like minus one he came back
and uh
in a six round tournament this is not
easy
yeah
and now he confidently beat voitershek
in the tie breaks
very very confidently for sure but the
question is what is wesley supposed to
do here
there's just no moose i mean what do you
play here there's rookie to ruji for
knight h4 rook h4 that's it
g6
rook takes h5 i can see this tactic
dominguez qualifies
dominguez meets in the semifinal against
lebaneroni and wesley so is out
well
and what a game
you know when you're linear dominguez
you're lost in this variation against
wesley so in the classical portion but
now making this comeback in this complex
structure